I think it was shellenberger that
exposed the basically the the
homelessness in the homeless industry
the industrial complex it's an industry
absolutely and they they receive money
every year to fix it but instead of
actually getting homeless people homes
they just pay the administrators the
bureaucracy to maintain the status quo
you still have the same people are still
homeless and they keep making everything
kicker to so I'm sorry I'm talking about
Miami-Dade it's what I know so pardon me
you know but um in Miami-Dade County the
person who runs the homeless trust which
is who has all this money is Ron book
who is the largest
um what would this be lobbyist for
government so I mean that's I guess his
reward is he gets to run this thing and
you know he's been doing it for I want
to say about 20 years you said that
there's the same amount of homeless
people every year or the new people like
are the people getting off the street
and the new people are arriving or is it
just tough to tell tough to you look at
a number it's three thousand but I mean
everybody so where I live there's not a
whole lot of homeless because they
generally live in downtown